JOEL LEWIS: Hi.
Welcome back to recitation.
In lecture, you've been
learning about line integrals
of vector fields.
And I have a couple
of nice questions
on that subject
for you right here.
So I want F to be the vector
field whose first coordinate is
x*y and whose second coordinate
is x squared plus y squared.
And so what I'd like you do is
compute the line integral of F
around two different
curves C. So both curves
start at the point (1, 1) and
they end at the point (2, 4).
So in part a, the curve is just
the straight line that connects
the point (1, 1) to (2, 4).
And in part b, the curve
is this sort of piecewise--
it's two sides of
a rectangle, right?
It goes straight up until
it gets to the point (1, 4),
and then it goes across
to the point (2, 4).
So it's a piecewise
smooth curve, path,
that connects those two points.
So I'd like you to compute
the integral over each
of these curves of F dot dr. So
why don't you pause the video,
have a go at that, come
back, and we can work it out
together.
So, when you're computing a
line integral over a curve,
really the thing
that you want to do
is you want to
parametrize the curve,
and then that gives you
stuff that you can plug in.
You'll have
expressions for x and y
in terms of your parameter.
So you can plug it in and you
just turn this integral right
into a nice single
variable integral,
and then you can compute it.
So that's our basic strategy
for computing integrals
of this form, line
integrals of vector fields.
So let's have a go.
Let's start with part a.
So in part a, what we need
to do to apply this method
is that we need to parametrize
the curve in question.
So this is a straight line.
And if you look at it, it's the
line through the points (1, 1)
and (2, 4).
So this line has equation
y equals 3x minus 2.
That's our line, and OK.
So we need to choose some
parameter that will give us
this segment of this line.
So a natural thing to do in
this case is-- it's easy enough,
y is already written
in terms of x,
so it's natural
enough just to take
a parameter that's equal to x.
So it's up to you whether you
introduce the letter t in order
to do this, or not.
I'm going to do it with the
letter t here in part a,
but you could do this problem
exactly the same way just using
the letter x.
So what I'm going to do is
I'm going to let x equals t
so that y is equal
to 3t minus 2.
OK, so that is the parametric
equation for the entire line,
but we only want the part
between the points (1, 1) and
(2, 4).
So the part between the
lines (1, 1) and (2, 4)
is the part where t
is between 1 and 2.
Where x is between 1 and 2.
OK.
So this is our parametrization.
So now we need to
figure out what
is the field F in
this parametrization,
and what is dr. And then
after we have those,
we can just put them into
our integral and compute.
So F, in this
parametrization, well,
we take the equation for F,
which is x*y comma x squared
plus y squared, and
we just plug in.
So in this case, x*y is going
to be 3t minus 2 times t,
so that's 3 t squared minus 2t.
And x squared plus y squared,
well that's t squared plus 3t
minus 2 quantity squared.
So that's what F is.
And also we have that dr-- well,
we just take the differentials
of x and y-- so this is
going to be dt comma 3*dt.
Or if you like, 1
comma 3 times dt
if you like to
factor out your dt.
So that's what F and dr is.
So now we need to
compute our integral.
So the integral over C of F
dot dr, well, you just plug in.
So this is the
integral over C now.
So OK.
So now we need to
look at our bounds.
So the integral over
C means the integral
as t varies in the range
that we need to cover.
That whole curve.
So in this case, we said that
was from t equals 1 to 2.
So it's the integral as t
goes from 1 to 2 of F dot dr.
So in the first coordinates--
let me factor out
the dt at the end.
So that's going to be 3 t
squared minus 2t, times 1,
plus-- OK, well, let's
expand this out now.
3t minus 2 quantity
squared, that's
going to give me a 9 t
squared minus 12t plus 4--
so this is 9 t squared
minus 12t plus 4,
and then we have to
add t squared to it.
So this is plus 10 t squared
minus 12t plus 4, times 3,
and then this whole thing is dt.
dt is the whole
integrand, there.
I could even put in another
pair of parentheses just
to emphasize that, perhaps.
OK.
Now this is a
straightforward-- I mean,
it's a little
complicated looking,
but it's just an
integral of a polynomial.
Easy enough to do.
Let's first just combine terms.
OK, so let's look
at the t squareds.
We have a 10 t squared times 3.
So 30 t squared, and
then another 3 times 1.
So 33 t squared.
And I've got minus 2t
minus 36t is minus 38t,
plus 12-- 4 times 3-- dt.
OK, and now we integrate.
So this is equal to
11 t cubed-- that's
a 3-- minus 19 t
squared plus 12t as t
varies between 1 and 2.
And all right.
OK, so now we've got to plug
in and evaluate and so on.
So at 2, this is 88 minus 76
plus 24, minus 11 minus 19
plus 12.
So you do some
arithmetic and this
is going to work out to 32.
OK, so there's part a.
It's a nice, simple
curve, so we had
a nice, simple parametrization.
We computed F and dr, then we
dotted them, and integrated.
OK, so now we're going to do
the same exact thing for part b,
but in part b, the curve is
a little more complicated.
Let's come over here where
we've got some empty space.
So in part b, our
curve looks like this.
So it starts at
the point (1, 1),
and then it goes up
to the point (1, 4),
and then it goes over
to the point (2, 4).
All right?
So it's hard to parametrize
in one fell swoop
something that makes a
sharp right angle like that.
So a natural thing to do
is to split the integral
over this whole curve into
the integrals over the two
different pieces.
So let's call this vertical part
C_1 and this horizontal part
C_2.
And so we know that the
integral over C of F
dot dr is equal to
the integral over C_1
of F dot dr plus the integral
over C_2 of F dot dr.
And so now, it's easy enough
to parametrize these two
separate curves separately.
C_1, for example, is the
straight line segment that
goes from (1, 1) to (1, 4).
So C_1.
So that means we have x
equal to 1, and 1 less than
or equal to y less
than or equal to 4.
So a natural
parametrization here
is just the parametrization
that uses the parameter y.
Right?
So in this one, I'm not going to
bother introducing a new letter
t.
I'm just going to
stick with x and y.
So we have x equals 1,
and y is our parameter
and it goes from 1 to 4.
So now let's look at
what F and dr are.
So in this case, F is equal to--
its first coordinate is x*y,
and x is just 1
here, so this is y.
And its second coordinate
was x squared plus y squared,
and so that's going to
be 1 plus y squared.
And dr-- well, r
here is 1 comma y--
so dr is equal to 0 comma dy.
Or (0, 1) times dy, if
you wanted to factor that
dy out to the end.
OK.
Good.
So we're all set to do
that first integral.
So let's do that.
So we have the integral over C_1
of F dot dr is equal to-- well,
we dot these two
things together.
And the first term gives me
y times 0, and that's just 0.
So that's going to
die, and all we're
left with is the second term.
So it's the integral of 1 plus y
squared dy, but we need bounds.
Right?
OK, so y was going from
1 to 4 in this integral.
So it's the integral from 1
to 4 of 1 plus y squared dy.
OK.
So we can either continue
and evaluate this now,
or we could go and
do the second one.
Let's finish evaluating
it since we've already
got it written up here.
So this is equal to y, plus y
cubed over 3, between 1 and 4.
So what is this?
This is 4 plus 64/3,
minus 1 plus 1/3.
So that looks like
it's 24 to me.
OK, so we get 24
for the first part.
Now, let's do the second part.
So C_2 here.
I'll draw a little line
there to separate them.
Now, curve C_2-- let's go
back and look at it-- OK,
so curve C_2 is the segment
connecting the points (1, 4)
and the point (2, 4).
OK, so y is always 4 on this
curve, and x goes from 1 to 2.
So 1 is less than or equal
to x less than or equal to 2,
y is equal to 4.
So a natural
parametrization here,
again, is just to take
x to be our parameter.
And again, I'm not going
to introduce a letter t.
We're just using x
as our parameter.
So in this case,
F-- well, it's x*y,
so x is just x and y is
4-- so that's 4x comma--
and the second coordinate is
x squared plus y squared--
so that's x squared plus 16.
And dr is equal to dx comma 0.
OK, so that's F and dr.
So the integral that I want
now is the integral over C_2
of F dot dr. OK, so we just
plug in here what we've got.
So this is equal to
the integral of-- well,
the first coordinates are 4x dx
and the second coordinates just
give me 0-- so it's 4x dx.
And again, I need my bounds.
Well, I had-- over
here, I had 1 less than
or equal to x is less
than or equal to 2.
So that's the integral
between 1 and 2.
4x-- integrate that-- and I get
2 x squared between 1 and 2,
which is equal to
8 minus 2, or 6.
All right.
So let's see what we've got.
So we had-- back here, we had
our curve C, which we split
into the two parts C_1 and C_2.
And we wanted to know what
the integral over C was,
and we've separately computed
the integral over C_1.
And we computed that to be 24.
And we computed the integral
over C_2, and that was 6.
So the integral over
the whole curve of F
dot dr is equal to 24
plus 6, which is 30.
OK.
So there's your answer
for the second part.
Now one thing I'd
like you to notice
is that over this
curve C in part b--
over the whole
curve in part b-- we
got that the integral
of this field F was 30.
And now if you
remember, right here,
in the first part, in part
a, we computed the integral
over a different curve
that connected the two
same endpoints.
And we found that the
integral came out to 32.
So one thing you should
take away from this
is that the integral over
a curve joining two points
can depend on which
curve you choose, right?
So we had two
different curves and we
got two different answers, even
though the two curves connected
the same points.
So that's interesting.
And the other thing
to take away from this
is just the general approach.
Which is that whenever you
have a problem like this, what
you want to do is you
want to take your curve--
so whether it be-- well, in part
a we had this straight line,
slanted line.
In part b where we had
this nice piecewise
linear with these vertical
and horizontal parts--
you want to break it into
nice pieces, parametrize them.
You know, sometimes
you only need
one piece when it's an
easy-to-parametrize curve
like that.
Sometimes, if it has
corners or so on,
you might want more pieces.
Break it into pieces, choose
a nice parametrization,
and that reduces your problem
just to computing integrals,
just like we've done in
Calculus I-- in 18.01--
and then you just integrate.
All right.
I'll end there.